well Sarah Palin is really having a
tough one it turns out a lot of people
in Alaska just don't like her Sarah
Palin you might remember uh former mayor
of Wasilla former governor of Alaska
although she quit that job former
um running mate to the late Senator John
McCain in 2008 she was the vice
presidential running mate she is now
running for the House of Representatives
um she was on the phone with uh real
America's voice which I guess is Steve
Bannon this is the War Room Steve Bannon
show and she is very triggered that her
fellow Republican Lisa murkowski from
Alaska
is supporting Palin's Democratic
opponent and you really do love to see
it it's quite a rare thing here she is
complaining to Steve ballon Bannon they
won't help me even Republican Lisa
murkowski is supporting a Democrat this
is a delight my friends
he actually is the other day he's not
voting for me in my race she's not
voting uh for the Republican party she's
actually literally announcing that she's
voting for the Democrat in my
congressional race so that I don't win
that's what I'm up again yeah well
listen it is a delight it's rare for a
sitting Republican to back any Democrat
and in particular when you're a sitting
Republican as is murkowski who is up for
re-election in two weeks and she's
supporting the Democrat in that race
Mary peltola Lisa murkowski cannot stand
Sarah Palin that's what's going on Palin
quit halfway through her term as
Governor of Alaska it rubbed tons of
alaskans the wrong way they don't like a
quitter Lisa murkowski doesn't like a
quitter and Lisa murkowski I mean listen
it's sort of like the the Susan Collins
thing right
Lisa murkowski will sometimes say
slightly more sane things than many
other Republicans at the end of the day
she mostly still votes with Republicans
but okay she doesn't like Palin and
she's not voting for Palin and Palin
seems to be losing very very badly
there's a new article from the
bipartisan report from a few weeks ago
and uh it has the the latest polling
data and the key paragraph is this one
um peltola starts in round one because
they have ranked Choice voting voting in
Alaska peltola starts in round one
meaning initial results with almost a
majority the progression of the results
puts peltola against baggage for a final
tabulation unlike the results from the
special election that gave peltola her
currently unfolding stint in Congress
when Palin made it to the end in these
results paltola finished with 54 of the
support baggage at 45 eliminating
baggage before the final round instead
of Palin still show Republicans losing
with peltola nabbing 56 percent of
support there evidently wasn't enough
crossover among the Republicans
supporters on either side and this is
the signal this is the data on which it
is believed that Sarah Palin is just not
consolidating enough support
um to actually win this and 65 of
alaskans Express negative feelings about
Sarah Palin so it is not looking good I
believe this is the end of are Palin's
political career if indeed she loses
this election let's hope that she does
we have viewers in Alaska Alaska a
unique state in a lot of ways culturally
geographically Etc I believe Palin will
lose all the evidences that she will
lose and hopefully that will be the end
in terms of hearing from Sarah Palin and
her political career let's hope